salut à tous vous êtes chaud aujourd'hui
je vous apprendre à danser la de leurs
modèles on accueille les danseurs ses
minimoys est prêt on dément retourner
c'est de retourner à gacé 3,4 y est
c'est parti là si sexy les épaules en
arrière on avance un peu on est sexy
ouais je suis beau 360 et je piétine en
gardant bien l'ange dans la viande
voilà rabouillet ça c'est mes boys tous
leurs modèles
alors on y va tout seul chez vous aussi
vous êtes chose vous n'êtes tout compris
allez musique c'est parti
arte
de leurs modems alors on va compliquer
un petit peu parce que je suis sûr vous
avez le niveau
alors quand vous êtes ici on complique
un peu avec les bras à chaque fois oui
ça c'est bien ça c'est bien et le final
attention le pas je m'offre de leurs
modèles vous avez tout compris vous êtes
chaud alors je vois toute la prudence et
c'est là de leurs modèles
à voir les boys bravo c'est vous et ont
très vite pour une nouvelle de leurs
modèles
m
de leur côté
à modène
s